mesdames et messieurs bonsoir on vous
parle d'abord du chili où un tsunami
s'est déclenché dans l'océan pacifique à
la suite d'un puissant tremblement de
terre d'une magnitude de 8,3 au large
d'une ville minière du nord du pays
ça s'est produit il y à un peu plus
d'une heure karine qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quelles sont les
informations qui sont disponibles en
fait depuis quelques temps il semble
qu'on sente et effectivement quelques
secousses précisément à cet endroit
et voilà c'est venu il ya à peine une
heure donc ce tremblement de terre ce
qu'on peut vous dire c'est que selon les
données qui indiquent que donc le
alertes du tsunami dans le pacifique
les données indiquent qu'un tsunami
s'est déclenchée huit minutes plus tard
la marine chilienne confirme que les
premières vagues ont atteint certaines
côtes du nord du pays
donc avertissement de taille dans
plusieurs pays notamment le pérou
l'équateur la colombie le panama
nicaragua costa rica donc on demande aux
gens de s'éloigner s'éloigner quelques
can am en vous voyez sur les images donc
les gens et qu'ils prennent leur voiture
et qui doivent elles un petit peu plus
haut en montagne présentement c'est ce
qui se passe et on ne sait pas
effectivement s'il ya eu des blessés
il ya par contre des glissements de
terrain qui ont été rapportés au cours
des dernières minutes donc on aura
sûrement d'autres nouvelles pour
l'instant c'est ce qu'on peut vous dire
là dessus très bien merci karine vous ne
revenez dès que vous avez d'autres
informations merci certainement au
revoir